foreign
has his eyes on the prize as he watches
his beloved Falcon take flight
training his Birds of Prey to race needs
skill and patience
this year his hopes are high for a win
in January's biggest Regional
composition held in Qatar
heading into the desert isn't just to
pass time for most catteries it's
actually a way of life
thousands of years Bedouin tribes in the
Gulf needed Falcons to survive now they
celebrate them for their speed agility
and beauty
[Music]
it's our heritage we learned Valkyrie
from our fathers and grandfathers
Falcons were used to hunt birds and
rabbits but it's different now we've
developed it as a hobby very few people
owned Falcons but that's changed
[Music]
racing season is on and prizes are in
their tens of thousands of dollars but
it's the prestige a champion Falcon
brings to its owner that makes all the
difference
Innovative technology and gadgets help
increase their chances of winning
well I've been assured not to feel too
nervous about holding this beautiful
Falcon from Mongolia it's about two
years old and it's due to take part in
the competition next month and if you
just take a look at the back here you
can see a GPS tracker and that's used to
see how far it will get during the
competition but it will there you go
look at that absolutely stunning
like all sports sometimes players get
injured and need medical checkups
Falcons are no different
qatar's only Falcon hospital has just
opened its doors and it's busy
[Music]
has an emergency room and treats around
30 000 patients a year
owners wait anxiously for a diagnosis
but at sometimes when you have a disease
you become very weak and we see his own
up how much he suffering when he see his
birth is very weak it's like his
children
what happened is it okay can you survive
what happened what's the problem can you
do something
other services include full competitors
than imping and that's the replacement
of broken feathers
[Music]
which feather has a role in the bird's
ability to reach speeds of up to 320
kilometers an hour Glide died and catch
its prey
procedure needs glue
a bamboo barbecue skewer
and a highly skilled technician
it's the weekend in Doha and ranam is
shopping with his friends in sukhwakif
market for a falcon having one from a
young age is a rite of passage for
Cattery boys passed down from generation
to generation
my budget is fifteen hundred dollars
there are two types of Falcons the Wild
Ones and ones that breed I want to buy a
wild one
well after a bit of price haggling
random is Happy says with his choice he
plans to train his Falcon to hunt and
race
and he's already given it a name which
is Arabic for famous
[Music]